hey what's going on it's bill burr
and it's time for the monday morning
podcast for monday
july 27th if you can believe it 2020
what's going on how are you
oh my god where is the summer going
i have to tell you my flip-flops have
never been in better con
condition this far into the summer
um i don't even have a [ __ ] belly yet i
mean this is [ __ ] ridiculous
walking around i got more material over
my face than i do over my muff i've had
it
um anyway you guys enjoying the summer
do you have your
little circle of people that you trust
that you trust that they're not out
there
[ __ ] [ __ ] around you you don't
know who you can trust man
you don't know who you can trust because
you know what everybody could be cool
in your [ __ ] group but there's one
person he's out there cruising hookers
or doing something
you know going out to get some air quote
chinese food
you know comes back 45 minutes later
with some cold sticky rice
where else did you go buddy where did
you go
[Laughter]
um here's a question i got to go on the
cduc website if you bang a hooker
wearing a condom while wearing a mask
um can you still uh
show up with your pot of friends with
your key lime pie the next day
you know these are the questions that i
if i ran a news network would be
answered
um anyways how you guys how you doing
how you doing
uh i hope you guys are enjoying your
summer
your quarantined summer you gotta admit
as much as it sucks that you're not
seeing it
your friends it's kind of great to not
see everybody else
you know and if you really do the math
and you think about it you only have
they say you only have two or three
really good friends
in life okay and everybody else
is just background a jerk-off or a
complete [ __ ]
you know so it's kind of good to get you
know
sacrifice seeing your true friends
you know to avoid all those other people
don't you i would think so
you know i'm kind of enjoying a little
bit who can know you guys have heard
i've slowly i've slowly gone out of my
[ __ ] mind here
a couple of times but i'm back uh
been flying a little bit here or there
you know
made sure everybody got tested but i
don't know what the [ __ ] that mean who
the [ __ ] knows what it means who knows
what it means i'm sick of [ __ ]
talking about it but what else do you
talk about
huh am i gonna sit here and tell you
guys every i don't have guests on this
thing usually
i need to start having guests hey man so
what what
uh tell me about the nothing you did
this week
um i'll tell you what did [ __ ] bother
me is there's there's a video going
around
it's a great george carlin bit
about how all politicians already bought
and sold and blow all the stuff that he
was telling us
you know in his final years and
like everything these [ __ ] [ __ ]
on the left
politicized the thing they made it seem
like he was only talking about
republicans because
all they showed in the video was
trump and uh mike pence and all of these
[ __ ] people
you know judges that the republican
right wanted that [ __ ] guy
uh whatever the [ __ ] his name was that
you know
nobody wanted to get no people didn't
want to get appointed and all that type
of [ __ ]
and that's it completely was not what
the [ __ ] he was saying
and it really bothers me that that guy
is no longer here
and somebody is taking his bit and doing
what fox and cnn do
like now regular people are doing it
they're making it
they're taking what he said and then
they're just putting it through the meat
grinder of their own [ __ ] brain
and their political agenda and
um i saw a few people posted it and then
all you just see is people
arguing about it underneath so then his
message
is now lost because you politicized it
sound familiar we kind of did that with
uh
the supernova cold we're all dealing
with [ __ ] politicizing and it goes
right down the [ __ ] toilet nobody can
that really bothered me because george
carlin obviously being a comedian is one
of my favorites of all time
and i really think the work that he did
towards the end a lot of people didn't
understand if you go back
and watch it the guy was so [ __ ] dead
on it was ridiculous now you can say oh
you didn't have as many jokes blah blah
blah he also didn't have a lot of time
left
so i think at some point the jokes were
getting in the way of some of the [ __ ]
he just kind of stepped outside the act
it was giving people a [ __ ] heads up
or whatever i don't know but it was it
was
really disappointing to see that bit
and to not see you know
show like just show an even amount of
politicians
so people can [ __ ] i mean somehow
meet in the [ __ ] middle i don't know
but let's get you know
i'm sure you guys have seen it you know
if you're on
on the [ __ ] interweb there um
but anyway uh let's talk moto gp
motogp the latest race in the south of
spain
whatever the heck the name of the time
was i already forget uh i saw that race
this morning
fabio cuatro wins race number two
mark marquez tried to race
this guy broke his humerus last week
four days later he he did 50 push-ups
on camera um i watched a little clip of
it and lit my eyes were watering just
waiting for his [ __ ] arm to snap
lunatic [ __ ] lunatic so he actually
tried to qualify for the race i don't
know how many times he went around the
track but
his right his right hand started going
numb throttle front brake can't
and uh obviously he can't be [ __ ]
going along at 200 miles an hour
with a numb hand so he ended up bowing
out
and um it was a uh
i don't know it was a very interesting
race it was so [ __ ] hot out there was
so many bikes that were just crapping
out like literally smoke coming out of
the back of them and [ __ ]
uh davitzioso i don't know what happened
i tried to look it up i just was so damn
busy something happened to him in the
uh he didn't crash or anything he just
didn't have a good qualifying he started
it like 14th or 15th so i got to watch
him move up through the field i think he
got to like sixth place
but um anyways fabio cuatro he just got
out
front and um what's his face valentino
rossi was in second place and
valentino could not keep up with uh
fabio cuatro and uh
what's his face uh maverick vignales
could not get around
um what's valentino rossi and then
it just i don't know it kind of looks
like a formula one race where like lewis
hamilton gets out in front and then the
[ __ ] race is over and you do the rest
of the the uh
rest of the race the cameras on people
in like
you know second through fifth place or
something like that but it was still
a fun race to watch and um
i know it was cool to see uh valentino
rossi on the podium but here's a
question i have for all you gearheads
out there
i don't [ __ ] understand how you age
out of that sport
i know it take because it i know it
takes a tremendous toll
on you um
physically so i guess there is that but
there's something because you're on a
machine and the machine is doing
so much of the work i just don't
understand
if valentino rossi keeps himself in
shape which he has
the guy's thin is a rail he's as light
as anybody else's on a bike
um if his bike is set up right
why is fabio so much better is it
simply because his body is younger and
he can just take the g-forces
um pulling on his body better that
valentino rossi can at that age it just
kind of fascinates me
that you can age out of motorsport i
mean
i guess i understand a little bit better
because we went to vegas and i drove a
car around a track
you know at like one-third the speed
those bikes go and
even just five times around my brain
felt like it was uh
it needed a break so i can't imagine at
those speeds
what that does to you i think i'm kind
of answering the question myself but i
would love
you know i get a lot of people writing
in you know
yelling at me about my [ __ ] about masks
you know
just getting really yelled at uh i never
really
dipped into and i don't still don't
consider it a political pool but i just
feel like i did
because it got politicized um
but you know for the record i was
watching this this moto gp race and
everybody in the pits was wearing masks
and
the winners when they were talking they
had [ __ ] masks on and [ __ ] like that
and uh i don't think spain and motogp is
in on some sort of conspiracy
to take down um [ __ ] red tie or blue
thai people i
i don't think that they give a [ __ ] but
that's
you know that's just me so whatever so i
watched the race and um
so now that uh fabio cuatro has won two
races you get 25 points
per race mark mark has crashed the first
one could not
race in this one so now fabio has gotten
he's got 50 points in two races 50-point
lead
and uh the next race isn't for a couple
of weeks i believe and then they do
three in a row
yeah the next one isn't until august 9th
um so august 2nd they have off then they
have august 9th
the 16th and 23rd huge month
um then they got a couple weeks off and
then in september's the 13th
20th 27th uh week or two off then
october 11th 18th 25th
and then november 8th 15th
and the other ones in argentina
uh thailand and malaysia are all
to be uh to be determined
what date they're going to be um
hey bill now that you're a moto gp gp
fan what
race would you like to go to i would
definitely like to go to one in spain
um the one in mexico city that goes
through the old uh
baseball park i know they do that in f1
i believe
motogp do they go through that wait
they're not even on the schedule here
i thought they raced down there i got to
do something in mexico city every band
or
that i've ever anybody who's ever gone
there said that city is incredible
um yeah so i'd say that one and then
whatever
track in italy there is plus those are
my favorite bikes i love the ducatis or
ducatis
as they say uh the announcers say um
i love those bikes and there's a track
where it has the fastest straightaway
where they get up to like 315 320
kilometers or something like that which
is i don't know 200 something miles an
hour
on a [ __ ] motorcycle while you're
racing somebody else i mean
it's incredible what these guys do all
right enough with the moto gp stuff
um i did watch a little bit of american
sports i watched the braves take
me out to the ball game they beat the
[ __ ] out of the mets
um to the point i just started tweeting
about the game so i could just somehow
stay involved in it
uh they won like a 14 to one i think
hanging out you know with my family and
every time i looked up they were just
[ __ ] hitting another home run
and uh it was fun to watch though i
actually really enjoy
i'm kind of enjoying sports without
crowds
in a way because um
i don't know when are you ever going to
get to do this again
it is interesting and they've been
miking up the players obviously on a
delay
i've always you know i like to think i'm
mature enough person that i could watch
like every player miked up and listen to
everything that they [ __ ] say
and not you know get offended or
anything like that it is unfortunate
that there aren't enough people like
that or like me i guess is what i'm
saying i just feel like for me
i'm like the perfect person no um
because i would love to because a few
times i've gotten to sit courtside on an
nba game and you just hear all the [ __ ]
talking and all that it's [ __ ]
amazing
amazing and uh especially the stars and
you're like sitting there watching like
that yeah this guy
really gives a [ __ ] you know because you
know all the [ __ ] [ __ ] in the bar
this guy doesn't [ __ ] care he's got
his money he's got his [ __ ]
and you get down he's like no this guy
gives a [ __ ] um
i was talking about kobe because i saw
that i saw the uh rest in peace and i
saw uh
the knicks courtside against the lakers
a year when the knicks of course were
[ __ ] horrible
and um the knicks actually beat him
and i remember kobe was [ __ ] pissed
um that they were losing to that team
and losing in new york at the garden and
all of that and i was down there and
like
he was single-handedly trying
to get this team to win i can't remember
what year it was i do remember i was
supposed to go to the game with patrice
rest his soul so he was still alive so
it was
pre 2011.
um god damn it man
that was probably
like oh five now when i think about it
was it that long ago
[ __ ] i'm old jesus christ
um anyway yeah so i watched them uh
beat down the braves i tell you one of
my i do one of the things that makes me
want to smoke a cigar oddly enough
is baseball you know
and i would actually sit there and
[ __ ] keep score
and all of that [ __ ] if i actually uh if
i could go to a cigar
bar um
whenever that day comes back around
again but uh i'm not smoking
this month and i don't think i'm gonna
smoke next month either because i kind
of worked it out where i hadn't smoked i
quit smoking on
january 13th i'm like i'm [ __ ] done
with this [ __ ]
and then i smoked one with verzi in
march so i didn't smoke in february
i smoked one in march none in april two
in may
and then seven in june that was a rough
one okay i had a kid
my birthday father's day got a little
off the rails so i need a couple of zero
months here
um i might go to like october or
november or something like that although
it's been
i don't know there's just been a few and
the bad thing that i do is i follow la
aurora cigars
on uh on instagram
and every time they they send a picture
i just go oh god that looks delicious
jesus christ i was trying to do once
every 50 days i think that that's what
the [ __ ] i'll do i'll just get back to
that so right now i'm i don't know
if i go this whole month 31 days
and i smoked on the 29th 3133
i guess august 27th i'll have my next
that's not bad right any doctors out
there
everybody's a doctor today right
everybody nowadays everybody's a [ __ ]
doctor
everybody knows what's going on
medically in the world
um i played some drums people i got
nothing i don't know what to tell you
i'm trying to think that i watch any
[ __ ] tv
anything that i liked i can't even
remember but i i
i bought some new drum heads and i've
been just tuning up
tensioning up the drums and [ __ ] and
just kind of learning how to do that
and uh got a really good sound and i
kind of realized like
you know i bought this kit right and i
got a 12 13
rack and then 14 16 18
um floor tom so it's kind of two kits in
one because i always play one up
in either one down or two down right so
i looked at it like i could either go
small 12 14 16 or bigger
like go 13 16 18.
so i was just changing the heads and
what i had
set up was i had the 13 rack and the
16th floor that's it
so um i decided to change the head on
the 14 right so then i had the
i had 13 14 16. so
with the sizes it was very easy
to go to go from the 16 to the 14 that
dumb
dumb and then when i wanted to get dumb
on the 13 it just it was too close to
the 14
where it wanted to be so i ended up
taking that off and put the 12 on and
then there was the tone that i wanted
so my question is to you drummers out
there that have these monster kits
when you go like if you have a 12
to a 13 or a 13 to a 14 how do you
tension that thing or what pitch is it
like a half step
is that what it is um because i've
always had like
two inches between drum sizes for the
most part
so it's been very easy i remember a long
time ago the guy goes it's like the
first two notes of here comes the bride
here
comes here comes you just kind of move
it all the way up
that's how i was taught to kind of do
the thing um
but i don't know how to go like i can
tune
12 14 i mean sorry 12 14 16
to sound good together but 13 14
16 i can't get 13 and 14 to sound good
uh and then 13 and 16 have too big of a
gap at that point
i'm sorry this is like major drum nerd
[ __ ] if anybody can help me out with
that i'd appreciate it
um and then lastly that [ __ ] that i was
talking about with drums as far as
like um being relaxed
the faster you go the more relaxed you
have to be
um if you're gonna execute it i've
really been working on that
and i sort of gave up while still
practicing good times bad times like
going i i've given up on
forward progress of this i just want to
be able to play it at this tempo and i
just started
just humming the song in my head well i
set the click to like 70 72 bpms
right and
i just did it i was like i don't give a
[ __ ] how long i have to stay at this
i'm just gonna play it until i can play
this without even thinking about it and
it took me like a week or so
you know in dad time you know and um
then i got really comfortable with it
and then i just sort of moved it up
i don't know i was just playing i was
like what if i just put it up to 80
after a month a week of playing at this
and i was able to play it at 80. now i
wasn't totally relaxed but i was able to
do that
and today i came downstairs you know
when i i practiced again and this time i
just sort of bumped it up to like 73.
and i messed around and jammed with it
at that humming the song in my head
bumped it up again to 80 and it was a
little bit easier so i think that that's
what i'm doing so now i'm just going to
sort of live at 73 bpms
forget about 80 and just get super
comfortable where i can just
you know there's like
there's three different ways he does
that 16th no triplet
he has one where he does three in a row
then he has there's a guitar solo part
where he
one bar he does three in a row then the
next bar he does four in a row
and then he has the epic one in the end
where
two bars in a row he plays that lick ten
times in a row
and um so i sort of play the song and
then i also think of just those bars and
i'll just sort of play him one after
another
completely not even of the song just
going back and forth
playing the drum fill that he plays
in the beginning or the drum fill that
he plays in the uh the chorus and just
playing it in any random order just at
that tempo
um and i don't know for whatever reason
that's really been helping me so if
there's anybody any other dad drummers
out there
who have limited time and are frustrated
this way of practicing
has really uh helped me and had me
way less frustrated um
i don't know it's really amazing how
that whole [ __ ] thing works and i
found the same thing
flying a helicopter because i was
holding on to so [ __ ] tight to the
point like the low rpm horn was coming
on because i was gripping
i came back and i was you know i was
like fighting the thing rather than
and my instructor was just going like
this thing wants to fly
so you just have to like and if you're
holding on to it super tight you're not
going to be able to
feel it and become one with it it's like
you just have to sort of
like feel which way it wants to go which
way the wind is pushing it and then just
make the right
inputs and it just totally changed
the way i was flying from one lesson to
another and it was like a noticeable
difference so
you know i mean it's sort of a thing
that happens when you're a new pilot
you grip like i don't want to [ __ ]
die so you kind of have a death grip on
but he said something really fascinating
i'm really getting into like nerd [ __ ]
here on this one
i got motorcycle racing fans drummers
drum tuning and now flying a helicopter
sorry at some point
when the questions come in this will get
a little more mainstream
so my instructor said something the
other day that just blew my [ __ ] mind
because i had the i was doing the best
auto rotations i i think i've ever done
and the hardest part for me for me
was when the ground's coming up
in other words you're getting closer to
the ground because you're really
descending way faster than you would
obviously
in uh no engine failure if you're coming
in
ideally 300 feet per minute is how you
want to come down that's commercial
level landing you know you always want
basically people can drink a hot coffee
and not spill it on themselves it's
supposed
it's supposed is how you're supposed to
do it right um
so when you're coming down like that in
an auto rotation as you're getting
closer to the ground
your natural instinct is to pull back on
the stick
which causes you to go into your flare
too soon it also causes your rpms to go
through the roof and then you have to
adjust that
and then you're making all these inputs
as you're coming to the ground so what
you really have to do is just sort of
stay in the pocket
and keep it level you also if you go
back too far you could have a tail
strike when you hit when you get too
close to the ground so as you come in
you actually want to stay level even
though
you're seeing the ground coming up and
you you want it's almost like you're
pulling your legs up you're pulling the
stick back
you want to stay level until you get
into your flare
and then the flare is as i was talking
is like
a hockey stop you're not you don't want
to go back up again
because if you go up that's going to be
the last of your energy and then as
you're coming down
when you pull those your what looks like
the emergency brake
to cushion you're going you're going to
have to you're going to be too high
and you know you're going to blow out
the skids or
[ __ ] up your back or something like that
if you're lucky that's the worst you're
going to do so
um what he said to me was
the helicopter is actually the most
happiest
thing he said during an engine failure
because there's absolutely no
stress on
on the the whole thing at all there's
nothing
competing there's no more main road of
torque being compensated
you know with the uh tail rotor and all
that stuff it's all
[ __ ] in sync and you're still
flying it and it's just i don't know
i don't know i don't even know who the
[ __ ] i'm talking to i feel like i'm
talking to eight of my listeners at this
point
let me do uh let me do a little bit of
uh
advertising reads here i'm sure i'll get
criticized for everything that i just
said
you don't know [ __ ] about motorcycle
racing i don't i don't know [ __ ] but if
you what you'll notice about me
is i'm all over the [ __ ] map all
right uh
oh look what it is it's for hymns
everybody for hymns.com for
com is all about men's wellness well
it's about time
everything's been about the ladies
need help with hair loss yes i do
erectile dysfunction
hey man you're talking to me or have a
cold
my dick has a cold it won't stand up and
the hair and my balls fell off
jesus christ i have to go to for hymns
oh sorry all right
interested in mental health or covid19
home tests
hims is here for you get the [ __ ] out
they got they got the home test for you
stay in the kitchen until you test
yourself gonna have families yelling at
each other personal endorsement should
be at the beginning of the spot
well you should have wrote that at the
beginning uh discuss the challenge men
face getting going to
a doctor and getting care for issues
they are uncomfortable with
yeah it's no fun going into a doctor
being like yeah hey my dick doesn't work
you know because you know at some point
he's going to yell out
uh to his secretary hey can you clear my
schedule this guy's dick isn't working
you're like
can you not yell that oh sorry you gotta
understand i look at flaccid dicks all
day so you know to me it's like nothing
this is just like time to make the
donuts so there's
really no reason to be embarrassed uh
anyways but but really
are very normal and treatable uh i guess
talking about dick problems or hair
problems
um share your story if you've used hymns
struggled with hair loss yourself oh the
struggle is over baby
[Laughter]
i have packed in this season we are in a
rebuilding year on top of my head or if
you had friends or family who have
may have experienced with it well those
are their stories i would never tell
about that
all right 60 can't you just [ __ ] talk
about your product i mean if you can
clear
baldness a [ __ ] flaccid dick and give
me a covet test i don't think you need
my
uh personal endorsement here just tell
the people how to get it all right
problem
66 of men start to lose their hair by
the age of 35.
does it seem like you're moving ahead in
life but your hairline is moving
backward uh that's one of life's cruel
jokes
uh maybe your dad had to settle for hair
loss but thanks to
to hymns you don't have to um it's time
to prevent more hair loss and no better
time than while you still have some
um thanks to science hair loss can be
optional that's [ __ ] great
uh hims connects you to fda approved
products to treat hair loss and they
have
thousands of happy customers loving
their results
time at home is an opportunity for
self-care
hymns will connect you to licensed
medical professionals
online to answer your questions for free
and to see if fda approved products to
treat
hair loss are right for you if approved
products will be shipped directly to
your door
okay if approved i'm sorry products will
be shipped directly to your door in
discreet
packaging it won't say erectile
dysfunction
pills it won't say hey baldy
here are your bag of plugs or whatever
they give you uh
hey anyone can make claims about
treating hair loss but
if you're not happy after 90 days just
email
hymns for a full refund now how many of
the hair loss people are doing that
this is why these guys are solid or
these ladies whoever's running this
country
country i'm sorry this company today
hymns is giving you their best offer yet
if you're not happy with your results
after 90 days hymns
will give you a full refund and right
now my listeners can get their first
visit absolutely free go to for hims.com
bird b-u-r-r-e-d oh bur
erectile dysfunction that is easy to
remember b-u-r-r-e-d
hey i'm offended uh that's for hims.com
bird all right
you know what you know what what should
happen is all balding and bald men
should form a union and what we should
say is we're not buying
another [ __ ] hair loss product
until you just give us the cure
okay that's it i'm done
we know you know how to do it we know
you know how to do it there's no
[ __ ] way if they can grow a [ __ ]
ear in a petri dish
you can't cure baldness it doesn't make
any sense
um can you [ __ ] imagine
if that [ __ ] pill came out um
you don't be so weird is i would
probably take it and then still do the
shaved head
because i have to be i'm kind of used to
it now because i'm growing my hair out
right now because i got a [ __ ] little
acting gig i got to do here hopefully
and i kind of got an idea but you know a
different look you know it's a different
guy you try to look a little different
even though you still have your same
stupid accent they're freckles
um and i find it just to be a pain in
the ass
um i just got used to it
i liked it you know
i kind of like it um but haven't said
that yeah i i would i would definitely
take the pill
and then i would just i would have the
option
you know if i wanted to or not is how i
look at it
i don't know who gives a [ __ ] i think i
think it's really for younger people
that
haven't found a mate yet okay and you
want to act like
you have the good genes all right whoop
there it is
here we go whoop everybody whoop has
been all over the news
lately
[Music]
after the pga tour procured 1 000
straps for its golfers caddies and staff
to help everyone at tournaments stay
safe throughout this pandemic
what is a strap we gave these guys guns
what the [ __ ] they
they were strapped whoop has been using
respiratory rate to help members detect
potential signs of illness before other
symptoms develop oh
has recently partnered with strava
so you can now upload your act
activities automatically from
to strava with recovery sleep and other
metrics
oh i though this is this is the little
band you put on and it attracts you
sleeping
can help anyone perform better whether
it's preparing for a golf match
race meetings etc
can help plan out your day and make
smarter lifestyle decisions
to help you feel better than ever this
is amazing this type of technology
if it's in the right hands um
that you can actually see like what
you're doing to your body
uh the whoop journal and monthly
performance assessments allow you to
track the decisions you make during the
day and actually see what impact those
choices have on your recovery
sleep and strain that's
literally treat it's like treating your
your body like a race car
uh sleep coach is custom tailored to you
and calculates your sleep uh needed base
your sleep need based on a variety of
data points with the ability to set
levels to peak
perform or get by depending on what is
planned for the following day
um that is amazing check your progress
in real time and finish your workout
when whoop
has let you know you've pushed your body
hard enough
i wonder if that would help with my
shoulder rehab because i think i went a
little too hard with two pounders
but i'm going to take a few days off ice
them up and stuff
uh the key to whoop is that you wear it
all day long and never miss a beat
whoop has a really smart charging system
where their battery pack
slides right on top of the strap so you
never have to take it off to charge
you won't even have to worry about
losing a night's sleep or missing a
workout
whoop is offering 15 off when you use
the code bur burr at checkout go to
woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
dot com and enter the code bird to save
sleep better sleep better recover faster
and train smarter
with today all right there you go
there you go those are the reeds those
are the reeds man
all right let's let the old man here get
a little sip of water here
um there we go
but he dumps it all over his [ __ ]
shirt what a [ __ ] idiot
jesus christ um
you know what it is is this [ __ ]
dermis remember the beers that had the
extra wide
opening at the top of them for like the
[ __ ] alkies
[Laughter]
you [ __ ] you know large
largemouth bass opening that they would
have that's what this [ __ ] thing has
so unless i'm standing up if i go to
port it always comes down either side of
my chin there
um all right let the youngsters let
youngsters have their fun
you know something have i come off as
this much of a [ __ ] every [ __ ] week
there's somebody giving breaking me
breaking me balls there all right here
we go i guess i opened my mouth so i'm
gonna get some [ __ ] all right hey bill
i'm a random pole from the uk
uh by the way i forgot that mikey
stremski grandson of karl yastremski
is in uh major league baseball
that is so [ __ ] cool can you imagine
what are the odds if he also wins the
triple crown
i mean that's never [ __ ] happened
that that's that is incredible
i can't imagine the conversations he
must have
with his grandfather about hitting and
and and just baseball in general i mean
that's like
talk about a mic'd up conversation you'd
love to hear
um all right hey bill i'm a random poll
from the uk
uh big fan and with tremendous and with
tremendous sense of humor parentheses
you know what's coming right
oh oh cause you're saying you have stop
being such a hypocrite bill
wait a minute stop being such a i've
been a hypocrite since i've been doing
this [ __ ] podcast
you named me one [ __ ] thing i've ever
said and then i didn't go and do the
exact opposite [ __ ] thing
that's this whole podcast what are you
gonna say next uh [ __ ] you suck at
reading out loud i mean i know this [ __ ]
anyway some young dude wrote to you
about being lonely
and unable to amp his guitar you
sang you smacked him with sanctimonious
that's evil
okay did i well yeah go play your
[ __ ] guitar don't breathe on an old
person
how am i the bad guy
i just don't i don't get it this has to
be a generation gap i didn't say he
couldn't play his guitar at the beach
i just said and even in the end i said
maybe i was too hard on that guy i
[ __ ] said it in the podcast
you [ __ ] you random pole [ __ ]
from the uk you're not even listening to
me
all right how's that different from
righteous protests
which you described as it needed to
happen
how is that how how is it different
playing a guitar on the beach
as opposed to a group of people that are
being murdered by the [ __ ] police
that are supposed to be protecting them
jesus [ __ ] christ okay
all right who are you gonna [ __ ] on next
firefighters who have to go to a fire
and give somebody mouth-to-mouth when
this you know during a pandemic they
shouldn't [ __ ] do that
all right i guess i guess yeah i guess
i'm the [ __ ] because
you know i i don't see how uh whining
that you can't
plug your guitar into a [ __ ] amp when
you live on the goddamn beach you're in
your 20s
you don't have any dependents
you know i i i don't know
and how that behavior can i don't know i
don't know
i mean what was supposed to happen with
the other side am i am i supposed to
tell them when they're supposed to
[ __ ] protest
i'm just saying okay if you're some
[ __ ]
do i really have to explain this i guess
in your world those are the same things
hey you know what
agree to disagree anyway to be clear i'd
rather see all people having a
discipline
and refrain from putting others in
harm's way tremendous
so you agree with me
all right but once you say this group of
insert
your favorite cars here can do it then
you are justifying everyone else
no i'm not if you're [ __ ] mature
because
i didn't look at those protesters saying
please stop
[ __ ] killing us and then go
well if they can go outside then i could
go to the beach
um no i'm not justifying everyone else
what you're doing
is you're saying that um i 100
disagree with that sir all right uh
catholic
with their unhygienic dispension of
crackers
i didn't say that they should do that
muslims with kissing certain holy sites
i wouldn't do that either orthodox
jews buddhists hindus etc all of them
like to gather and extensively breathe
in each other's direction
well in my country you're not allowed to
go to church as far as i know at least
in this state you can't
um this is even more disappointing with
your persona
oh jesus christ i don't know
when you stop talking to me like i'm
your son and i [ __ ] disappointed you
you [ __ ] whiny [ __ ]
this is even because of your persona
listen to this quote why do we need to
jump on ebola
let it burn through once or let's
sink random cruise ships routines
all right buddy you know what i mean
thank god i went to poland
and i saw how many smart people were
there or i really think that the
stereotype was true
buddy are you really sitting there
trying to tell me that the
jokes did you really when i said that
they should have let ebola burn through
the population
you really thought that i was being
serious do you really think that i want
to sink cruise ships with women and
children
innocent people on it i was making a
joke about how we weren't doing anything
about the population problem
so that you would then have to go to
these ridiculous absurd
levels to try and control it
okay i thought the fact that
it said comedy special before you
clicked on it
and that people were laughing
hysterically
as i was suggesting sinking cruise ships
that you knew it was a joke evidently
you didn't
and now your mind is blown okay and now
on the other side
of this lovely sandwich oh this guy this
lovely sandwich he's really getting into
himself he thinks he's making some
points here
there is no malice in everything above
i'm trying to break your balls with my
broken english because i love you
oh god the mind [ __ ] of this thing so
then you didn't mean any of that
or i guess you did yeah i'm not being a
hypocrite okay
i'm just trying to do what doctors are
telling me to do not what people in the
news are doing and i'm sick of talking
about this
because evidently some of the people who
listen to this podcast
are just a little too i don't know what
a little too delicate or maybe
it was were you just trolling the whole
time is that what the [ __ ] it is i don't
know
i don't know um but by all means just go
out and do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do because
uh you know i don't know just getting
[ __ ] yelled at every goddamn [ __ ]
week here i am
and the goodness of my heart and the
advertising money i make on this
i am trying to bring laughter no all
right sidecar racing all right here we
go here's a nice subject here
good morning billy international
sportsman burr
have you ever heard of sidecar racing
yes i have i've actually talked about it
on this podcast and i can't think of a
more thankless job
than being [ __ ] not only are you
riding [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] beneath the guy who's got
all the commands and then you have to
literally
stand up while this thing's going 100
something [ __ ] miles an hour
and lean over the other side of the bike
when he's making a [ __ ] left turn
i mean
you can't tell me at some point
that that guy doesn't want to be the guy
riding the bike
i mean that that is literally like a
will ferrell character
in a movie the guy in the side car
um and walking around like he's the
[ __ ]
like i don't think he's the man or
something i don't know have you ever
heard of sidecar racing yes i had i just
happened to see it on reddit and i know
you would like it it's basically a
two-man teen driving in a 600 cc
motorcycle
one is the main driver and the other
person sits in the side car you got to
see this if you haven't seen it's
incredible
uh you have to youtube it and watch the
guys sitting on the
side cart maneuver while taking turns
it's unbelievable the balls
to move the weight around while the main
driver is doing
tight turns uh would you do this race
oh when i ride in that race if yes who's
your partner
who's your sponsor i would help i would
hope this
i i hope this helped entertain you for a
little bit
while being locked down please visit
tacoma washington
all right be safe um
would i do this race no
i wouldn't i am
i am a control freak i would want to be
the one making the decisions of how fast
we went into the [ __ ] turn
um i i
i'd like to think i'm a good team player
it would take me a long time to get
comfortable
like the level of trust that you have to
have with the guy
riding the bike as you're going into
this turn being like he's going to apply
the right amount of pressure at the
right amount
at the right time and we are not going
to hit those trees and because i know
that i am now
going to stand up and lean over
the other side of the [ __ ] bike
i mean if he ends up laying that thing
down i mean you're sliding on your face
i know you have a full [ __ ] shield
but you're gonna do a face plant into
the [ __ ] ground
if he somehow high sides it you're gonna
go
flying there's no nobody wins in a high
side but you're gonna go flying up in
the air
backwards um
oh okay now i have to look that up right
now all right there we go let's see here
by the way nhl coming back august 1st
right
uh high side
uh
side car
is it cart motorcycle
let's see what we get here
oh psi car come on man give me a video i
wanna i wanna see it
the coolest motorcycle ever a little fun
i didn't write the right thing come on
man let's just say
sidecar sidecar
motorcycle racing
crashes here we go
massive crash the tt
2014 sidecar race so these guys probably
died
all right under the [ __ ] tree oh you
guys want to hear this
likewise know that they've got to stick
with you if they
want to win the race
[Music]
all right where's it gonna happen it's a
[ __ ] minute 10 long
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh my god if you could put the three
stooges on a [ __ ] motorcycle that's
what i just watched
jesus christ oh my god that is just all
kinds of [ __ ] that
there is no [ __ ] way there is no
[ __ ] way oh my god
all right if i was gonna do it uh my
partner
it would be alonzo bowden uh he's into
motorcycle racing and he's ridden
forever so i would try i would of all
the
if i had to partner up with the comedian
it would be alonzo bowden
or dean del rey alonzo might be too big
i'd be worried about all of that weight
so i would have to say dean del rey
and um i don't know dina or alonso
that's that would be it who would our
sponsor be all thinks comedy of course
uh you like that you like that all right
divorced after six months uh
dear billy bald balls um
now i'm thinking about that let the
youngsters have their fun was he just
[ __ ] breaking my balls
maybe that's what he was doing i don't
[ __ ] know
i i don't even know anymore i don't give
a [ __ ] i just want to get back out and
tell some [ __ ] jokes
and make people laugh um
all right divorced after six months
this sounds like a [ __ ] sitcom that
didn't get picked up
divorced after six months we shot a
pilot but it uh didn't work out uh dear
billy bald balls
love the podcast and hearing your take
on situations
that being said i need some advice oh
wait a minute
he [ __ ] he lobbed it over the net
come on come on where is it
oh by the way rest in peace peter green
one of the greatest [ __ ]
guitarists of all time and the only
reason why i know anything about him is
because of
uh marc maron
mark maron was the guy that taught me
about him now why can't i get to my
[ __ ] songs here
tv show music music music there we go
library library
i'm never gonna have a professional
podcast you guys just gonna have to
[ __ ] deal with that fact all right
this guy just asked for advice it's time
for advice hey
that's me
from somebody else all right the
hypocrite here he goes
the hypocrite uh divorced after six i
need some advice my ex and i dated for
five years and i just knew
she was the one after nearly a year of
being engaged we decided to get married
after only six months of being married i
came i come home the friday before
christmas after working all day
to an empty house with no warning
and when i say empty i mean nothing but
my clothes were still there oh my god
like she paid for everything we don't
have any children but of course i
reached out to her with no success
asking if she'd be willing to go to
counseling
in hopes of working things out
and still no response i don't want to
blame the victim here but what did you
do
um a few days later i noticed she posted
a status on facebook about me
claiming i was mentally and physically
abusive to her
and continued to explain to everyone on
facebook that's why she left me
and that she was unhappy the whole
nearly seven years
that we were together why did she have
to go on facebook and tell everybody
oh this is why i soon find out she was
cheating on me the whole time we were
married with the guy she worked with
we finally decided to move forward with
the divorce but in my state we
have to be separated a year before we
can finalize the divorce
so here's the kicker when my ex left me
she forgot
a bird house that her now deceased
grandfather built her
i texted her and told her she could come
by
and get it or i could bring it to her or
aren't you a nice guy considering she
took the tvs and everything
but she insisted that her boyfriend
comes to get it
i told her that wouldn't work oh yeah
dude you could [ __ ] crown that guy
with
the [ __ ] bird house yeah that's not a
good situation
you might snap uh since then she tried
to get alimony and tried to take my
house that i
owned before we were married with no
success
thank god all in the name of the bird
house that she claims i won't give her
so my question is should i be the bigger
person and let her boyfriend come and
get the birdhouse
or should i keep it just to prove a
point
to [ __ ] [ __ ] i hope you can help me out
with this and always as always go [ __ ]
yourself uh no dude
um this is the thing about
uh women when you break up with them or
they break up with you you got to get
them the [ __ ] out of your life
it's a cancer you got to get rid it's a
[ __ ] birdhouse
okay and here's the deal that guy
who's with that that that woman i think
you called her [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't know
if that's her first and last name or her
first in a middle name
um he's with her now
okay and now he has that's like what
about bob
i always use that analogy just pass her
on just
you know just give give him the [ __ ]
birdhouse
keep your house let that guy
lay in bed with her knowing how he got
her
okay and at some point you know you
probably end up doing the same thing to
him
uh which is not your [ __ ] problem
this is what you do you give him the
birdhouse
you know i don't that's that's
that's a tough this is what i would do
uh
you can't just leave it out because then
you look like a [ __ ]
when the when the guy comes to uh the
door
i i still wouldn't say anything
just hand him the [ __ ] bird house
yeah she's right
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] because she's
making you look at the person she was
[ __ ] while you guys were married
ah all right dude this is the thing
you this is what you have to do
in life when [ __ ] like this happens
okay cause i think she's trying to bait
you into swinging on this guy
okay and then somehow i don't know what
there'll be some new [ __ ] law
that if you punch the man that was
[ __ ] your wife while you were married
to her
she somehow gets your house that you own
before you guys were married like
there'll be
some sort of legislation probably in the
works
okay so i think she's trying to bait you
into doing something stupid here
so the stupid move is to keep the
birdhouse
the even dumber move is to take the
birdhouse and smash it over that guy's
head
all right the smart move here is to give
that poor bastard who's now with this
[ __ ] hort the birdhouse
and guess what they [ __ ] walk away
you know and you go crack open a cold
one and thank
your lucky [ __ ] stars you never had a
kid with her
dude she's gone she's out of your
[ __ ] life
okay and you move on and find
the good person that you deserve all
right
and just be lucky that you live in the
state that you live in
that actually let you keep your [ __ ]
house
okay that's it
all right um
i mean granted i just got your side of
the story but i think
you're either dealing with a psycho or
somebody who just didn't know how to
break up with somebody and just kept
moving to the next level of the [ __ ]
relationship
and then didn't know how to get out of
it and then did it in a totally
immature [ __ ] way that is not the
mature way to [ __ ] break
up with somebody i mean i'm all for
clearing your [ __ ] out
but when the person comes home you have
to be there
okay so it's a clean break so you don't
have to [ __ ]
then be living together and just going
through this [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean
you don't have to put your if you're
going to break up with somebody you got
to do it face to face
but you don't have to [ __ ] draw it
out for months on [ __ ] end
so the first half that she did cleared
the [ __ ] place out i don't have a
problem with that unless it's [ __ ] that
you also paid for that's a little [ __ ]
up
but that's how women operate and guys
don't give a [ __ ] whatever you can
always get another [ __ ] table who
gives a [ __ ]
right but i'm telling you right now it
seems to me like she is trying to bait
you
into something and i also think on some
level you kept the birdhouse out of
spite
uh just let it go give the birdhouse to
that [ __ ] jerk-off
he can go get with [ __ ] [ __ ] and you
can you can
you know you can be with somebody else
who gives a [ __ ] dude they're out of
your life
that is a small small [ __ ] price to
pay
um and then you know what
she can focus all that psycho [ __ ]
energy on this new [ __ ] guy
you know because what's funny is in his
head he thinks that he's winning
you know so i mean they kind of deserve
each other
in a way right um
and then they'll bang and they'll have a
kid and he'll be a banker someday
all right doing time dear billy blue
balls
uh love the podcast and i hope you get
to perform stand up soon i saw you in
orlando back in 2015 and loved the show
oh i had a great time down there was
that the one at the uh
was that the one that was at the at the
house of blues or was that the
previous time i went there i can't
remember he says anyway
i hope you uh read this email and can
help me out i am 28 years old
and a medic in the u.s navy and i
absolutely hate what i do
all right well that's a big thing you
figured out that you don't like
something
that's a big thing and you're able to
say it out loud or at least send it into
a podcast
he goes i've been in the navy for four
years now and i have become more and
more miserable as the time has passed
well then don't re-up
like you i've always tried to do try my
best at jobs but even
if i didn't like them um
even if i didn't like them but i
recently i am starting to not work as
hard because i am so tired of being the
only person
that's trusted to get the job done i am
so overworked underpaid
that i can't even write it all dealing
with incompetent leaders
uh to being treated like a child and not
having
most of freedom taken away from me i
just can't take it anymore it's not like
i can curse out my supervisor
even though i would love to they treat
me and other sailors like absolute [ __ ]
like we aren't humans
uh because we're a lower rank than them
uh that's never good leadership
eventually your men will turn on you
there are a few easy ways to get out but
i wouldn't
get the honorable discharge that i
deserve
i only have a year left and i feel like
things are really boiling over for me
i am dreading every single day i don't
booze or waste any of my free time
because i am working on my plan for when
i finally get out
i stay productive in my off time i would
just like your thoughts on my issue here
the navy is constantly up my ass and has
total control over me
how would you handle being stuck at your
job you hate and can't quit please let
me know
all right here's the deal dude you gotta
man up and do your last year
all right they didn't force you to sign
up you signed up you put yourself
in this position okay and it's going to
be this great life lesson
all right you got one more year don't
[ __ ] this up
you were a medic in the navy okay
there's everybody respects that that's
always gonna look good on a resume
all right and you got a long [ __ ]
life ahead of you
and that's that's just gonna be a
[ __ ] a dishonorable discharge out of
the navy is gonna be a [ __ ] albatross
hanging around your neck unless all you
want to do is get out of the navy and
sell used cars or [ __ ] become a
comedian because there's no background
check
in show business or selling cars as far
as i know
um just tough it out dude
try to find the humor in it and um
i would just i you know
here's the thing this is the thing a
year from now
you're not gonna be in it anymore and
you're going to get an honorable
discharge and it's going to be the
greatest [ __ ] day of your life
your young life when you just walk away
from that [ __ ]
or you can leave now in a year from now
as you're sitting with that dishonorable
discharge in the navy that you're gonna
have for the rest of your [ __ ] life
like a tattoo you can't remove
you're gonna be thinking going man you
know what if i just toughed it out
i'd be getting out now all right you've
done four [ __ ] years
you got 80 of it out of the way you're
way away from crossing the [ __ ]
finish line
and having a [ __ ] beer and as many as
you want
and none of those [ __ ] [ __ ] with
more stripes on their shirt telling you
what to do
you can [ __ ] do it you can do it
all right i had jobs
that i [ __ ] hated i stuck it out so i
could be a comedian i didn't have
anything like you i wasn't married to it
i can't imagine what you're going
through
but if you've been able to do it for
four [ __ ] years
i would actually do an even better job i
would make the navy [ __ ]
beg me to stay you should [ __ ] crush
it in the final year
and get an absolutely glowing discharge
and then just get the
[ __ ] out of there get the [ __ ] out of
there and like oh my god i can't
like i'm getting i'm getting a [ __ ]
feeling of excitement as far as like how
you're gonna
i wish i could know what that felt like
actually i do know what that feels like
[Laughter]
i've had a couple of acting gigs that
seemed like they were never gonna
[ __ ]
end um i've loved every acting job and
every acting part
but there has been a few that i've been
on where
the shooting days got so [ __ ]
long and you did so many days in a row
that i just remem you know you know what
and i would always look forward to when
they were over and what was funny
was every time they were over i always
had a melancholy or a sadness
so i guess i don't know what that feels
like because i still
i mean i guess the difference is i do
love what i do so
um it is great you served your country
honorable discharge you now know that
you don't want to [ __ ] be a medic in
the navy
um that's a great thing to have on the
resume don't [ __ ] that up
especially if you if you been eating
[ __ ]
for [ __ ] four years you know
and they're going to give you the brass
ring and you're going to [ __ ] it up
don't do that don't do we don't get a
couple turns left
all right my transgender significant
other is never excited about sex
help all right now i i
i had my buddy look this up to make sure
this was a real thing okay this is a
real thing
hey old saggy balls bill i'll have you
know
my balls are still high and tight uh i'm
a bisexual lady oh god bless you
who's been dating a trans man woman to
man
okay for a little over six months
that's fascinating so when did you when
you met the person were they already
starting
to trans whatever you're supposed to say
there um
by the way speaking of trans how great
is the trans am
you know late 70s 6.6 liter i mean the
[ __ ]
all right let's stay focused here for a
little over six months we have been
we have a happy and healthy relationship
and enjoy one another's company quite a
bit
he gets along well with my family and
friends and vice versa
and it it has so far been the best
relationship
i've had in my adult life all right so
what's the problem
oh look there is just one problem
he never seems excited to have sex with
me
we very rarely have sex and when we do
he hardly lets me touch him this is a
huge problem for me because i'm very
physical
physically affectionate person and i
believe that being able to touch your
partner is half
of a sexual relationship i have
expressed this to him i was gonna say
you gotta say something
you gotta say something i have expressed
this to him before
and i can see that he has made the
effort to be more open
but he's still pretty closed off to me
well is he self-conscious because he's
going through this this
change he's going through
changes um i've tried to be
understanding and patient because i know
that
as a trans man he's uncomfortable in his
body there you go and likely
uncomfortable sharing it with other way
i already forgot which way he's going
woman to man all right but i just
can't help but feel a little starving
for a normal sexual relationship and
affection
he sometimes makes me feel embarrassed
for wanting more
well that's not fair to you for example
we were on vacation
and drove past a store called sexy stuff
yes
with only one f sexy stuff
s-t-u-f and i joke that we should go and
get some fun vacation vibrators there
he responded what makes you think that's
a good idea
oh boy and continue to grumble about how
stores like that are lame
and not made for trans individuals
what should i do i don't want to break
up with them because we work so well
together outside of this issue
but i'm just not satisfied with that
portion of our relationship
give a girl some advice also your
podcast keeps me sane thanks
um give me some advice i mean i don't
know what to do here
um i think you need to
decide out of the [ __ ] blue
you need to decide what's more important
staying with this person
and um i mean they can't help how
they're wired
if they're just a less
sexual person than you are
um
i don't know that's a tough one
well do you love the dude i mean i don't
know what to tell you
this is something you have to decide on
your own but i think uh
i know personally i can say that if
there was
if i was with somebody that i loved and
the sex life was not where it wanted to
be
that there would be a distance
um that would build up
um and it would be hard to not resent
or just feel like you're being i don't
know
just shunned on some level
and i don't think you're being selfish
if that's how you feel so
i i think
um i mean i don't know you've sat down
you've talked to them about it
and i i think
judging by what he said about the the
sexy stuff one f store
i think that there's a window of
opportunity there where
i think um
you know i can't imagine what that's got
to be like be one sex but really
identify with the other the [ __ ]
thunder and lightning that's got to be
going through your [ __ ]
brain trying to make sense of your world
and then you're transitioning and then
having people
treat you and weird and all of that [ __ ]
they're probably going through a lot of
stuff maybe you can talk to the person
and see if this is a
they need to like they just need time to
get adjusted to their new body i guess
um i don't know i mean that's
that's outside my world as far as
you know where i'm at but
um i was definitely with some women that
weren't comfortable with their bodies
and you know you just kind of have to go
slow
i guess is what it is and be
understanding and uh can't make any
jokes
it's a very sensitive type of thing so
i don't know if i helped you there but
um
i think what you the only thing you can
do is try to help the person along
and see if it's something that through
therapy and talking that they're
eventually going to get to an acceptable
place
for you and if that seems like
they can do that and they want to do it
then this is worth staying in but if
they're never going to do that
then you have a decision to make which i
can't make for you
uh that's it but if they just from what
you wrote granted as
always it's one person's side of the
story this person seems a little walled
off and seems a little s
uh you know
like why would you think that would be a
good idea it's a very
i don't know could be fun i think that's
very like
walled off um seems to go beyond
actually that seems it's a very
like highly emotional reaction to
a stupid sex store um
so i don't know if you can drill through
that [ __ ] bedrock
with a vibrator from sexy stuff one f uh
maybe you can get through i don't know
um all right underrated everybody
having a lazy ass girlfriend
okay when the under under when there's a
mountain of dirty dishes and [ __ ]
sprawled all over the [ __ ] living
room when there's a literal
ass shape indent on the couch from this
lazy broad watching eight straight
episodes of whatever shitty chick flick
she's into now
that's underrated uh when the garbage is
overflowing and the dog's gotta
piss at least i know when i get home
after busting my ass all goddamn weak
that she's way too [ __ ] lazy to go
out and get [ __ ] by some other dick
and that brings me peace
oh my god
wow yeah that binge watching thing
is i i've done that a few times i
haven't done it in years
and uh i always feel terrible about
myself afterwards
you know when it's like 3 30 4 in the
morning
and you're like uh don't watch another
episode of netflix just
it just keeps going you just sit there
and sit there and sit there it's uh
i don't know all right well
the mask wearing hypocrite is signing
off
um thank you for everybody for listening
um
and like i said rest in peace uh
peter green i am not listening to all of
your music
and uh everything i have listened to
mark maron
had a nice tweet about the passing of uh
peter green
and sent a link to this song albatross
or something like that which was of
course
beautiful piece of music and all that
and then which got me to the link of his
uh
solo album which uh i want to download
but i feel like
because he just died a bunch of newbies
like me are going to go to itunes and
then they're going to [ __ ] make it
like nine
times the cost and price gouge the
[ __ ] thing now if it was going to him
and his immediate family then that would
be a good thing but i kind of have a
feeling it's gonna go to
windex the windows of that round
building up there and [ __ ] silicon
valley uh who knows whatever i'll buy
the [ __ ] album okay that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves and
uh get well soon mark marquez
so i can see if if you can run down
[ __ ] fabio cuatro that's it
i'll talk to you guys on thursday